in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Gordon
is with us hi Gordon how are you
probably doing any better I'll be named
Dave Ramsey
well welcome brother good to have you
and who's this young man with you this
is little Gordon little Gordon Gordon
and Gordon that works for me where do
you guys live Gulfport Mississippi fun
and you're here all the way from there
to do your debt free scream yes sir Wow
and how much have you paid off 16,000
cool and how long did that take you
right at 10 months excellent making what
kind of money after child support in
Texas about 3,600 a month okay excellent
Saro about 40,000 a year give or take
yeah all right excellent way to go man
so what kind of debt was the 16,000 Oh
there's a couple of stupid little things
credit card
student debt to college and the KGB IRS
okay I have the IRS and yeah little bit
everything that yes okay very cool so
what happened ten months ago that made
you decide you were going to get out of
debt well I've always been kind of
financially ignorant Dave but uh around
October November of last year the IRS
smacked me they put a levy on my
checking account took the 1200 that was
in there and I was broke broke it was on
a October 21st I believe it was and I
didn't get paid till the 1st and I just
had no money I didn't have anything in
savings I was living paycheck to
paycheck and I freaked out Wow
and then right after that a good friend
of mine Carly he uh he suggested your
book the Total Money Makeover and it
took me about a month and a half to
really get on board but January boom all
in cool yes sir and so from January to
October here we go again it's in by the
time you get to this October it's a new
world that's the plan I love it yes sir
cool and so when you paid off the last
debt in October I paid off the last debt
um actually yes right at right at
October 4th I believe it was yeah yeah a
year from the time the IRS woke you up
yes sir
so the IRS living in your accounts the
best thing that ever happened to you the
best worst
I don't don't do it again IRS please no
no no we don't want to have it it's not
good in that way but it wasn't you up
yes sir and sorry you've changed
everything huh everything at once I got
my finances on their order and I started
doing a budget like you suggested I
realized how much money I was spending
on eating out uh-huh and treating my
friends to eat and not even buying stuff
from us I was spending almost eleven
hundred dollars a month on food which is
ridiculous so you got under control with
that so when people hear that you paid
off sixteen thousand dollars in the last
ten months and they ask how did you do
that what do you tell them the secret to
getting out of debt is the majority of
them know because I'm kind of vocal
about Dave Ramsey's teachings but uh
really I say it's a couple things it's
one you know sticking with your plan
don't try to fix it I have so many
friends who are like yeah I have a with
the Dave Ramsey stuff but I have my pet
credit card that I've had since college
or mm-hmm you know something along those
lines and uh and really cash cash is
cash is king and that's that's
especially for me I'll spend I'm a free
spirit so with the credit card you'll
spend that huh oh yes sir okay
all right but cash keeps you from doing
that - does excuse me and check it hurts
when it goes out what's the hardest part
of this for you um really I'm kind of a
free spirit when it comes to money so I
think becoming a nerd learning how to do
the numbers and crunching it and making
myself do it and then I guess second
really would be saying no I mean 29
years old and single and a lot of
friends you know there's a lot of uh
there's a lot of things that you want to
go do with your friends whether it's a
music best or just going to the movies
and you just said yeah I'm good I'll
catch you next year so how old is Gordon
he turned seven on December 27 all right
very cool so has he been practicing his
debt-free scream you've been practicing
it yes okay sorry are you gonna be good
at it yes I think so
I got a feeling you may be the best
debt-free screamer we have today it's
very possible
although the bar is pretty high but I
think you can do it I think you can I
think you can be the winner of the day
so excellent
very cool very cool what's the biggest
thing you'd learned as you went through
this pay you taxes and really just
learned everything you can about about
finances I couldn't leave how many
things are were to that money could do
and it could not do and mm-hmm it's all
you at your money do something with it
making it behave yes sir absolutely
very cool that's a good word very well
done all right Gordon and young Gordon
$16,000 paid off in ten months making
40,000 a year that's pretty incredible
thank you you've been living on nothing
that's pretty stinking incredible count
it down let's hear your debt free scream
ready in three two one
good job buddy well done well done well
done that's how it happens right there
you guys would be so rich so fast and be
able to do so much not only for
yourselves and for your family but for
others